good morning John this video comes to
you in 54 parts each of which will
explain how to register to vote how to
get a sample ballot and how to vote in
each of the 50 states as well as in a
few other cases because we are the
United States of America and each state
establishes its own laws and procedures
so the process of voting is different
everywhere it's just part of what makes
America beautiful and a little bit
annoying but yes we did put together
over 30,000 words of scripts for this
project and yes it was a bit of a pain
but it's worth it because I feel that
voting is one of the most important
parts of being an American there are a
lot of different ways to vote not just
practically depending on where you live
but philosophically you can vote for the
world you most want to see or you can
vote for the world you think will most
likely bring change or you can vote for
just one thing or based on just one
thing how you want to vote is up to you
as is whether you vote but I want to
make sure that you understand that not
voting isn't some revolutionary
political act if you're not voting no
one is hearing your voice so they have
no reason to represent you depending on
where you live
registering and voting are varying
degrees of difficulty but in these
videos I'm making it clear if you don't
think the voting matters because no one
voter decides an election two things one
if everybody thought that way nobody
would vote except for one guy who was
just drunk and stumbled into the polling
place and he would decide how the entire
country got run so it does matter if
everyone who watches this video goes out
and votes we will we us will be an
important voting bloc second the
majority of government in America is
local and local elections do in fact
frequently get decided by one person
this is how change happens especially as
national government has become less
effective in recent years this is how
laws get made and how rights get granted
or taken away if you don't feel informed
on every issue it's easy to get a sample
ballot which I'll explain in your States
video and to do some research
it just takes an hour half hour of
research to help make America a better
place it's not hard it might be a little
complicated but we're gonna solve that
problem right now please send this video
or the corresponding state video to
everyone you know who might not vote
because it's too complicated or they're
not sure how we do not change this
country as individuals we change it as
to it it might not be fast it might not
be perfect but democracy does not work
if we do not participate you can now
click on your state's name to watch the
video on how to make sure you're
registered to register to get your
sample ballot and vote John I'll see you
on Tuesday